they didn't want me to create a Zed song
they wanted me to create a piece of
music that matches what this is all
about my first thoughts when the project
came to me was finally and excited
because I've made classical music in my
life I've always wanted to be more in
the scoring world and the way it was
presented to me is it's a project that
Darren Aronofsky is filming for Nat Geo
and I'm a big fan so I was immediately
interested so what I find really
inspiration about one strange rock is
that it's much more visually stimulating
and it keeps you engaged with the with
the topic and it was kind of my mission
to try to match that in the audio world
so the Sirius it's it's a lot about
seeing things from a different
perspective and even if you think you
know what a certain thing is looking at
it from a different perspective you
learn and you side of it and that's kind
of the thought behind this chord
progression as well the first half is
all one bass note and these chords this
melody that's really haunting you think
you've heard it already
but it never really opens up it's always
this question mark because of this pedal
note it doesn't move and then after that
big reveal you see that exact same
melody same chords but with a different
bass note and it opens up a completely
different emotion second step was
obviously recording that piano and then
adding elements to it
you know cinematic moments some hits
that really grab your attention
building a huge climax and then the
orchestra is a big piece I asked my
friend Brian Tyler to help me
orchestrate this piece I'm in the
process of the second half of the songs
which which is the big climax where the
whole Orchestra comes in
and I really want to find a way to add
my elements to it that sound like Zedd
but keep the epicness of this of this
choir in Orchestra so I'm still halfway
done I hope that when people hear this
piece of music that I mean it was one
strange rock that they will realize that
I am capable of writing emotional music
outside of what they think I can do and
I just hope that people give this a
chance and really listen to it and
listen to the intricacies and details of
the chord progression of and and how
this musical piece changes you when you
listen to it
[Music]
[Music]
you